pas combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait deux
pas plus chez ne vous trompez pas voter
bien sûr photo
il manque
[Musique]
en attaque il a répété sinon nous serons
jamais prêt pour la fête des fleurs il
vocalys gêne plus fort plus haut il
s'avère pas tête
mon niveau
oh vous avez vu mon tabouret de plus
peut-être nous la réparer il est très
forte vis maintenant chante la chanson
un deux trois voire
fuir mois
[Applaudissements]
tél
m
l'homme
pour
les patins
et
alors
[Musique]
bah
à
après
l'auteur
maintenant c'est à peine si tu me vois
des gens sont j'écoute ce petit
papa c'est un petit pas aux internautes
de faire lundi tôt ne cherchez pas c'est
un peu mon prochain
il faut pas plus cher
avec lui à 14 la chanson du pata plus
tous en choeur
[Musique]
m
pas du tout
[Musique]
tap au plafond
chaque match
[Musique]
ça fait une heure que je tape avec ma
canne qu'est ce que c'est que ce vacarme
infernal
ça ne veut pas du match en a besoin
c'est dur
c'est ridicule
à
pitié j'ai mal au coeur
là haut et
[Musique]
sac à papier c'est une invention superbe
superbe et involontaire combien 3g vous
qu'il y ait deux papas péché ne faut
trop décolleté bien sûr toi
wada a pas eu il nous manque un
[Musique]